you believe
reunimos a siete fans de black pink soy
fan de black ping soy fan de black ping
6 am de black pink soy fan de black pink
soy fan de black being soy fan de black
ping soy fan the black pink uno es un
impostor si el grupo descubre quiénes se
repartirán un premio en efectivo
y el impostor se queda ganará todo el
premio
quien es el impostor el impostor
fanáticos del black pink
tengo una idea primero hagamos el saludo
de black ping cuando van a subir al
escenario lo saben todos verdad si lo
saben bien todos listos no me hablan de
1 2 3 dígitos 1 2000 es
donde sabía el saludo mi confianza se
fue como dije acaso no soy fan si no me
sé el saludo quiero decir empecemos por
cómo y cuando conocimos el plan ping yo
los conocí en el pre debut durante la
práctica de baile de big bear en jazmín
margot yo los conocí con play with fire
si play with fire a mí me pareció un
poco fuera de lugar parece que le gusta
más le gusta twice durante la pandemia
mi primo me enseñó a vitti es y luego
busque grupos de chicas de key pop y
encontré a black ping y dije demonios
les conocí en 2016 me gustaron desde su
debut me encantaba to anyone
necesito algo que llene ese vacío y las
conozco desde el debut acabo de ver un
documental y me encantó la conociste en
el documental sí sí soy algo nuevo dijo
que conoció a black ping
cuando salió el documental me parece que
sabe demasiado para alguien que las
conoció durante la pandemia espera
ingreso favorito no sé no sé
de llamas channel lo recuerdo porque una
de ellas hizo la campaña de channel
solo me aseguraba de claro
creo que si la foto de los seguidores
quienes el impostor en la primera ronda
vote por noé creo que parecía estar
asustado cuando cuando hicimos el 123
vote por catherine porque tenía una
mirada que me resultaba algo sospechosa
[Música]
a menos
adiós chicos
supongo que no hable mucho estoy
decepcionado por no poder hablar sobre
las diferentes cosas que sé sobre ellas
tengo una pregunta para no sabes de
dónde son todos los miembros donde
nacieron sí y de dónde son jesús de
korea nació en corea y se crió en korea
rosen nació en nueva zelanda luego se
fue a australia y se que vivió allí un
tiempo
santo cielo jenny y desde nueva zelanda
y lisa es tailandés a mi atención estaba
en no es luego de la primera ronda pero
cuando comenzó a hablar pensé bueno no
creo que no es y sabe alguien las ha
visto en vivo yo sí fui el concierto de
los ángeles en realidad fue patrocinada
por kia porque dijeron ella es muy
fanática vamos a llevarla
al principio con catherine pensaba ella
es la impostora y solo es una fachada
tampoco sabía si sólo era una fanática
de cake pop en general pero no de black
pink sé que sospechas de mí pero creo
que soy la más fanática de aquí soy una
línea de verdad
que pienso en ti ji soo como solista
ella no es solista excepto por su
carrera de actores es verdad sólo tenía
su carrera
también que les parecen sus
colaboraciones con artistas
estadounidenses no me gusta a mí tampoco
y quizás makeup sour candy me encantan
todos dicen que ice cream
y ya está muy callado parece que no sabe
mucho
bote por chanel porque estaba callada me
sentí mal ella es agradable pero no lo
sé
aún no puede yo los odio a todos no es
broma me lo esperaba porque estaban
hablando mucho y la verdad es que no
hable casi creo que sólo me concentré en
observar todo si están seguros de que
atraparon al topo puede terminar el
juego ahora pero si la mayoría tiene
dudas el juego continuará por favor
levanten las manos si quieren seguir en
el juego
vaya bien es la mayoría nueva regla cada
vez que expulsen a alguien que no sea el
impostor se va a reducir el precio del
premio
porque piensan que ya no se encuentra el
impostor entre nosotros porque piensas
que no está haciendo que todos estamos
seguros o menos chané todavía somos
cinco las probabilidades de que sigue
aquí son muy altas me tocó me sentí
extraña porque fue como si estuvieran
seguros de que el impostor si estaba yo
pensando que lo habíamos tratado pienso
que el impostor fue la primera persona
que eliminamos qué tal si hacemos sus
bailes y podemos hacer cualquier luego
de los bajistas
nolan en un ambiente de uno en uno que
cada quien haga una canción diferente no
he ganado set
hay un like
en la tercera ronda yo estaba como de
acuerdo creo que voy a tener que bailar
voy a tener que mover el esqueleto hacer
una coreografía y esperaría que ellos me
crean
talará
está
muy bien bien
de quien sospechan justo ahora yo sigo
sospechando de ti no voy a mentir if yo
creo que está entre ustedes dos
eso permitir que soy un fan más casual
no soy un fanático al extremo pero si
eso no significa que no se levantan sí
tengo bien no tienes productos de la
banda no no no pero ahora sospecho de ti
como no puedo pagar una entrada al
concierto
vote por ian en la tercera ronda porque
los demás parecían saber lo que hablaban
pero ian era el más
tranquilo
y creo que no podría ser el impostor
porque dijo que no tiene mercancía
y contamos los votos si tenemos un
empate el empate es entre 9
que tenga ese puesto crecer no significa
que tienen que votar otra vez entre los
dos la elegiré a ella
cambie de opinión
vaya
de verdad me eliminaron qué bueno que
los hice perder dinero por favor
levanten la mano si quieren seguir
jugando
terminaremos el juego ahora si las luces
cambian a verde significa que expulsaron
al impostor y ganaron si las luces
cambian a rojo significa que el impostor
sigue en la caca y pierde vamos vamos
vamos creo que ganamos va a ser genial
[Música]
[Risas]
sí por favor que el impostor dé un paso
adelante y se revele en
3-2-1 yo lo odio
no me sorprendió lo supe al instante yo
era fanático de black ping por ellos
volví a escuchar queipo pero poco a poco
fui quitando toda su música de mis
listas porque ya no me gustan sus
canciones y desde que llegaron al
mercado estadounidense con ice cream y
todas las colaboraciones son malas no
voy a mentir es mi opinión es muy bien
decirlo él tiene una opinión no se
vuelvan locos solo por unos comentarios
dicen lo que quieren lo protegen
es verdad
gracias